true or false omg was invented in 1917.
true how is that true omg stands for the
exclamation oh my god the first recorded
use of omg is in a letter to winston
churchill dated 1917. true or false the
color red makes bulls crazy true false
bulls are colorblind what makes them
crazy is people stabbing them with
spears before the bullfighter gets into
the ring true or false some people can
hear the difference between hot water
and cold water
true no way cold water is more viscous
and makes it thicker giving it a lower
frequency and people listening for this
can tell the difference with almost 100
accuracy true or false sos stands for
save our ship or save our souls
false sos became a distress signal
because it's easy to transmit three dots
three dashes and three dots true or
false the first pilgrims landed on
plymouth rock
boss the first pilgrims landed in
provincetown plymouth rock wasn't until
five weeks later